while CES is almost out of clothes and
justin i'd say probably one of the most
important things you've seen here are
the different steam machines but I think
we've also learned that perhaps the
messaging isn't so clear and there are a
lot of different products for people to
consider what is your takeaway on the
you know the gamut of devices that
people can expect when they're shopping
for a steam machine yeah I mean they
come in all different sizes all
different price points from pretty cheap
too really really expensive a six
thousand dollar machine and you know
talking with the guys who are making
these one of the points that they made
is that they're going after the current
steam user user base and they're not
going after console mcgamer right now in
and I think that's gonna surprise a lot
of people who are expecting these to
come in and compete directly with ps4
and xbox one but they're not they're
going after people who who are PC gamers
already and have a huge library of steam
games yeah I think there's definitely
going to be some confusion in the
marketplace because the way valve
position these things initially was a
gaming machine for your living room and
that's sort of you know people conjure
up the idea of a console when they think
about that but you know some of the
devices we've seen that are priced
around the same you know cost as a
console maybe aren't as powerful as
people are expecting and may not be able
to match the power that people have you
know in a ps4 or an xbox one yeah i mean
if one of these machines can come in at
some point and be as powerful as an xbox
one or at least you know match that and
hit that same four hundred fifty dollar
price point then then maybe console
gamers would be drawn in a little bit
more but right now they're going after
guys who just want an extra maybe a
smaller pc to to put hook up to their TV
do that at big picture mode in a way
that's gonna be really easy for them
that they don't have to to make their
own machine and set everything up it's
just going to be something that they can
put in there I think one company that's
really poised to kind of capitalize on
this interest and really hit that sweet
spot might be alienware traditionally PC
manufacturers has sort of existed in
this wild west of a you know machine
manufacturing you have the really
expensive ones you have the really cheap
ones some of these brands aren't really
household names alienware is and they're
owned by Dell and they have this sort of
sway to perhaps get the parts cheaper
get people's attention because people
recognize alienware their box is small
it looks great and we don't have final
details on it yet but I would be very
surprised if if they didn't really
to tackle that console market out of any
of the other manufacturers and so I
think that's what people are really
looking forward to right is an easy
gaming PC for the living room they don't
just sit at a desk val is gonna give
them the controller but there is a long
way to go before this becomes a reality
it's still very very early these
machines a lot of them don't have
details on specs or price point so I
think even next year at CES we're going
to see a much different picture of the
steam machine and you know we're still
waiting for the steamos to launch right
so it's got a long ways to go we're
almost done here at CES it's been a
pretty good show hope you guys have
enjoyed the coverage we have a few more
things coming down the pipeline so stay
tuned to us on Twitter Facebook and
YouTube and of course gamespot com
thanks for watching